moix alors moi monsieur il ya plein de
choses que je n'aime pas dans votre
discours et je vais même vous dire il
n'ya que des choses que je n'aime pas
dans votre discours est souvent sont des
non dits le premier non dit il ya un
aspect religieux
c'est à dire que parmi les gens qui
défendent vos thèses il ya souvent des
gens qui sont catholiques voire ultra
catholique je trouve ça le trouve ça
scandaleux que vous quittez qu'est mon
discours non je vais vous dire et avis
est ce que vous lisez non ce n'est pas
demain non non non c'est étrange je dis
parlerez vous personnellement il ya un
arrondi et qui me semble d'autant plus
étonnant que la religion catholique
repose particulièrement sur deux
principes
une sorte de pma puisque c'est une femme
qui a fait un enfant toute seule et
qu'il n'ya pas de lien biologique entre
le fils de dieu et dieu donc que des
gens soient toute la journée en train de
donner des cours de biologie au prétexte
que les géniteurs et les parents
devraient se confondre quand il y
faisait mais rj une religion où
précisément le lien biologique n'existe
pas entre le père et fils est un premier
motif pour moi de risibilité le deuxième
non dit c'est l'homophobie
je crois que vous craignez tout
simplement sans doute que par une
éducation au sein d'un couple lesbien
les homosexuels fabriquerait peut-être
des petits homosexuels etc votre pire
terreur je voulais s'installant dans les
gagnants dans les guerres monsieur le
nombre charles péguy un de mes auteurs
préférés été élevé par sa grand mère et
par sa mère pour une raison pour laisser
un coup de charles péguy aussi c'est que
oui mais j'aime ce pour des raisons
symétriquement opposé aux autres assure
je suis sûr que si pour la raison que je
ne mens pas dans vos pensées mais mais
mais des vôtres sont tellement lisible
quelles sont elles font presque on n'a
vu venir une charge lui dans une minute
le nombre de générations de gens qui ont
été élevés par des femmes parce que leur
père était mort à la guerre de
militaires sont dit on à la guerre de
1914 où la guerre 240 et on ne voit pas
qu'ils étaient plus névrosé plus
malheureux que les autres agressions
comme un mille ont souffert la chose que
je vous reproche le plus souffert et qui
me semble
excusez moi parce que c'est pas un
procès à dominer mais évidemment vous et
je suis comme meurt à kehl je suis tout
à fait heureux de pouvoir débattre avec
des gens qui ne pensent pas comme moi
mais là où je suis vraiment mal à l'aise
c'est pas les deux premiers motifs que
j'ai invoqué c'est le troisième je ne
supporte pas les ventriloques ceux qui
parlent des enfants à leur place et ce
sont les mêmes qui font
zar pour les enfants qui font heidegger
pour les adolescents voyez ce que je
veux dire non si ba oui je ne m'étonne
pas vous voyez pas eu
il faut quelqu'un n'a pas de boire les
adultes et les adultes de prendre
prendre sa défense
le contrôlons toujours de la
ventriloquie et se met toujours à la
place des enfants et c'est pour cela que
ce que vous dites quand vous parlez de
l'enfant vous mettez à sa place vous
n'êtes pas un enfant monsieur j'étais un
enfant mais oui mais mal vous savez chez
les enfants il ya deux sortes de
d'enfants il ya ceux qui ont marre
d'être des adultes et ceux qui ont
oublié qu'ils étaient un enfant un jour
je ne sais pas quelle catégorie vous
appartenez mais en tout cas
et vous dans quelques cas une chose fait
partie de la catégorie de ceux qui se
seraient bien passés d'avoir un père par
exemple vivant donc si vous voulez
monsieur moi qui était maltraité pendant
toute mon existence
en tout cas jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ou 17
ans j'aurais rêvé par exemple que mon
père meurt dans un accident de voiture
mais je vais pas parler de mon cas
personnel
s'il veut dire que laurent seillier dit
quelque chose tout à l'heure et éric lui
a repris un peu la parole quand un
enfant et je vais dire une banalité ça
fait du bien de temps en temps quand un
enfant est aimé par deux êtres voire
même un seul il à des risques plus tard
de répercuter cet amour sous une forme
qu'il fera qu il ne sera ni psychopathe
ni psycho rigide ni névrosé ni
malheureux et qu'il n'était pas
d'instinct suicidaire et je vais vous
dire une chose je pense que aujourd'hui
il y a pas chez vous je l'entends une
forme larvée d'homophobie dans ce pays
qui fait que ça nous gêne que des
lesbiennes par exemple puisse avoir un
enfant alors que très franchement ça ne
nous ça ne nous enlève rien je ne vois
pas en quoi c'est le dépose cette de
savoir que un couple lesbien éduquer un
enfant avec l'amour que ça je me suis
lassé par sa demande